ينضم الينا من مخيم جباليه شمالي غزه
الصحفي عماد زقوت عماد نتابع معك اخر
التطورات في شمال
غزه نعم المدفعيه الاسرائيليه يتواصل
استهدافها لمناطق متفرقه من شمال قطع غزه
تحديدا في المناطق الشرقيه لبلده جباليا
وكذلك المناطق الغربيه ومنطقه بيت حانون
ومنطقه بيت لاهيه وكذلك وسط مخيم جباليا
منطقه الخلفاء يتم استهداف هذه المناطق
بشكل متواصل من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
الطائرات المسيره الاسرائيليه هي زادت من
وتيره استهدافها لتجمعات المواطنين وقد
استشهد ما يقرب من 15 مواطنا على خلال ال
24 ساعه الماضيه في مناطق شرق جباليا
وكذلك غرب جباليا منطقه تحديدا بئر النعجه
ومنطقه كذلك المقبره الفلوجه تم استهداف
تجمعات للمواطنين ادى لاستشهاد ما يقرب من
15 مواطنا في هذه المناطق التي تحدثنا
عنها كذلك هنالك اشتباكات حصلت بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وبين اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه في منطقه لتوام الى الغرب من
جباليا وايضا المسيرات الاسرائيليه
العسكريه هي تواصل تحليقها بشكل متواصل في
مناطق متفرقه من شمال قطاع غزه على
المستوى المعيشي الوضع هو صعب ومساوي جراء
منع دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى شمال
قطع غزه الموارد الاساسيه هي بتت تخلو من
من شمال قطاع غزه تحديدا الدقيق والغاز
والكثير من الموارد الاساسيه التي ادت الى
الى فقدانها وافتقادها في مناطق في شمال
قطاع غزه ايضا الاتصالات وشبكه الانترنت
والتيار الكهربائي
هذه منقطعه بشكل كامل عن شمال قطع غزه ادى
الى عزله كامله لشمال قطع غزه عن الاهالي
سواء في جنوب قطع غزه او
من يسكنون خارج قطع غزه وايضا هنالك لا
يوجد تواصل بين المواطنين بعضهم ببعض ايضا
داخل منطقه شمال قطاع غزه جراء قطاع
الاتصالات
والانترنت في هذه المناطق هذه الاوضاع
المعيشيه التي ايضا اجراءات الحصار الخانق
على شمال قطع على مدار ايام الحرب
المجنونه على قطاع غزه تحديدا هنا في شمال
قطع غاز الذي تعرض لحمم ناريه كثيفه على
مدار ايام هذه الحرب شكرا لك عماد زقوت
الصحفيه من شمالي غزه وبالتحديد كنت معنا
من مخيم جباليا